salut c'est robert deniro pour Brut je
ne sais pas quel genre de personne il écoute comment il
écoute je ne pense pas qu'il écoute et je
peux juste dire qu'est ce qui
ne va pas avec toi tu ne réalises pas certaines choses que
tu dis  et aidez ou n'aidez personne
et vous voyez probablement que je me fiche de ce que les
gens pensent, je pense qu'il y a une vraie
déconnexion avec lui et mais je ne le saurais pas
vraiment à moins d'avoir vraiment parlé
à un face à face que j'aurais  aucun
problème à le faire si jamais cela arrivait, vous savez
pour une raison quelconque, dieu sait s'il y aurait
jamais ouais comme un débat eh bien, vous savez,
je regardais qu'ils faisaient beaucoup de
couverture sur George Bush Senior et
disaient qu'il était une personne décente et
que  il a essayé de faire de son mieux pour
atteindre l'autre côté de l'allée comme on dit et a
fait des concessions avec des gens
qui s'opposaient à ce qu'il voulait faire et
maintenant que nous en sommes là, nous sommes là où nous en sommes
et puis je vois Bush je veux dire je sens
qu'il était un bon vous connaissez une
personne bien intentionnée et ne pouvez pas toujours
prendre la bonne décision mais il fait de son
mieux les intentions sont là et c'est
ce que je ressentais à propos d'Obama c'est l'intention de
bonnes intentions étaient là les bonnes
intentions pour tous les Américains Je pense que
beaucoup de racisme s'est opposé à Obama
et les gens n'étaient peut-être même pas  conscient
de toute façon, donc je suis fier d'Obama et de
George Bush Senior pour avoir fait de leur
mieux et Clinton, il y a des choses qui ne vont pas
avec eux et vous pourriez dire avec chacun d'
eux à un moment ou à un autre, mais ils
ont fait de leur mieux et ils  gardé le
pays sur la bonne voie,
je ne vois pas du tout cela avec
ce président, je pense qu'il est
important pour tout Américain qui se soucie de ce qui se
passe dans notre pays de
parler parce que tout le monde ressent cela, mais
vous devez dire quelque chose  et d'autres
personnes l'apprécient, je sais qu'ils m'ont dit
cela et je n'aime pas faire ça,
mais je me sens si profondément offensé par le
comportement de cette personne et ce qu'il a
fait pour démolir l'Amérique, ce sont des
institutions que les gens devraient spe  ak up ils
doivent le faire quand ils vont avec les choses
empirer ils le feront vraiment avec les
manifestations de masse vous savez que ce sera comme dans
les années 60
ce sera vous que vous avez vu juste après qu'il ait
été inauguré la manifestation de masse
et que oui les gens l'ont eu